CHRISTI PAUL.ITJENNIFER AND JAE
RIGHT NOW.IS WAS AFTER THE PAIAY
POCEND E IIDINIT, NOOM WHERE
LISTEN WE GOT RE, THAT POSSIBLY
TEOUR OFFICERSED
TTMINUTES.
WHHE
DID ILLANCECI R
ERKE THE FUGITIVES INT>> ATTNEI
THEIR SAFETY.
FOOWDAY'S  WHERE FOUR STUDEN
RS
IS
THE PA STE CHARGEBU PROSETOEY'V
>>OUEV IHOLDING THOSE PEOPLEREO
Y REASONLEFOE WAS VERYELINNT
AND THEY DID NOTNG NOTHING.
THEY ALLOWEDIMACK TO HOD OUT OFC
OU TO N'S N PONTIAC, MICHIGAN.TA
SAIDHEN D E NG
GIVEN SOME O  NIGHT DOESN
LIKE TY O TURN
EM IN.
TH N COMPLETELY IF THEY
WERE GOING TO TURNIN.
>> RIGHT.
>> Reporter: THEWERE IT, ABOUTMY
LLINTERESTG Y, GWORD T GOING
COULDN'T FIGE HEY
WO DOING IUTES, BUT IT'S A
BUSY PLACE.
WPRTTLE
TO'S WHERE THEY CET A
A TI CAR W
SEEN AT A , AND THE
POLICE JUST SWARMED .AWEAILARME
CE S.W.A.T MB THE E
OF DETIT LOOKING THEM.
VIDEO TONN OF THE ARREST, THE MB
RCOM WHHA DAY SEARCHING FOREY W
FOUND EMANA
.S REALLY INTERESTING HISAID TH
>> IN FACTTHD AN
WE'RE LOOKING IN
THE INVESTIGATION.VISION HAS
INFORMATTHE SHARING WITH
THANSHHEER
OMEONE LET
IN - THEY DIK INorter:S ?>> YES
RO VEAT
T LET THEM
T  NOW Y RGES A
THIS BUILDING E FOUND
INSIDE, CLEARLY, THERESOECTION.
LILDOT
THIS AND THAT'S ONE OS THEY S O
USED WHEN THEY WEROKG R G THEY
IL.EO FRO
LDING JUSTHOWS
MASSIVE RESPONSE FTH
ER LAW
FIND THEM.RY A
THEY ALLWARMED THIAREA
TRYING TO FIND
SUCTHEY FOUND THEM HIDINGN A
FIRST FLOOR  OBUEM
THE POLICE CHIEF TALKET  K
ORT  SD
STRESSEDEM
INTO CUSTODY.
BEING HIR.E
HRSEE THEMED THERAIGNED.
E KNOW YOUL R .
SHIMON, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> LET'SNGN
ANONSDALE.
THANK YOU SO COMMISSIONER,
R S.
THE NIGH PEOPLE, THAT THIS WAS
FOREMOSTWHFACT THEY WERE HIDINO
WERE IN DETROIT, TD
FIT . F ABOUT
TISTH TUR
HE ONI G  A
ON Y H TWAS YOF THEMUSE OF
WHAC
THRES KNEW STO YESAY
E THE SHTING, ABOU THEIR
SON HAID HD
WRTE TSE NOTES, ABT,, "HELP ME"
POSSIBLY BE MADE OF
PARE-- I THE  EXPLAIN WHAT THE
PARENTS O HAPPEN.
I WHATACRS IN INL,
HE HAD       S OBVISL AT TH THEE
THEY ENABLEDS, IT T R
HELP
ETK T'BE ASCAR I
THEYHE'S KILLETA OUT $
ABANDONING HIM.
DOES TACONAN PARENER
T  JUSAT
ORRIBLS.T'T BE NICT ISBL
TH LET THE KIDIRDOWN.
EVODOING TO SUFFER
BEUS TT'O , D PARENTS, AND THE
MUSTLD WITH R THEIR ACTIONS.FLI
G E CRUMBL
YESTY E ABLE SHERIFF
THE COLETH H
CHANANTO
BLE
ENFORCEM TOP OTHIS COUPLE IF THA
D H BETWEEN
D TH H
NEED T THE PARENTSD THE SON.WE D